Carlito, est-ce que cette
anecdote est vraie ou fausse?
Et bien cette anecdote, elle est fausse !
Salut ! Il y a seulement 24 heures,
Mcfly et Carlito ont enfin sorti
la vidéo où ils font un concours
d'anecdotes avec Emmanuel Macron.
Autant vous dire que j'ai été submergé
de vos messages me demandant
d'en faire une analyse.
Et surprise, je vais en faire une.
Mais attention !
Déjà, contrairement à d'habitude, je vais pas
être surpris parce que j'ai vu la vidéo.
Moi aussi, j'ai regardé dimanche matin à
10 heures la vidéo quand elle est sortie.
Donc, je sais à peu près
de quoi j'ai envie de parler.
Deuxièmement, c'est une analyse assez courte
parce qu'il n'y a pas énormément de
moments qui sont intéressants à analyser.
En vrai, il y a 3 / 4 moments
dont j'ai envie de vous parler.
Donc, je vais vous en parler.
Troisièmement, ce n'est pas une analyse
non plus où je vais dire
est-ce que c'est bien ou pas bien
qu'ils aient fait ça ou pas,
je m'en fous complètement.
C'est vraiment juste pour voir
qu'est-ce qui était intéressant
à voir sur Emmanuel Macron.
Et enfin, quatrième point,
bien sûr, cette vidéo va
passer pour une course aux vues.
Et alors clairement,
bah euh oui, dans le fond, vous me la demandez
vous avez envie de la voir, je la fais.
C'est aussi pour qu'elle soit
vue.
On est clair là dessus?
Donc voilà, je vais pas analyser Mcfly et Carlito,
mais juste
Emmanuel Macron.
A la limite, si un jour on veut faire
une analyse Mcfly et Carlito.
Là, il y aurait de la matière avec toutes leurs
vidéos et anecdotes
pour voir quand est-ce qu'ils mentent ou pas.
Si vous voulez,
un jour, on pourra faire ça
ou limite leur proposer à eux de le faire en direct.
Mais ce sera un autre sujet.
Là, le sujet, c'est juste Emmanuel Macron.
C'est relativement rapide.
Je ne prends pas parti pour ou contre le bail.
Et encore une fois,
j'utilise des techniques qui viennent
de plusieurs domaines de la psychologie,
mais aussi, de pseudosciences,
comme parfois des petits trucs de PNL
ou de synergologie où il y a
pas mal de trucs à jeter.
Donc, ça ne reste que mon avis,
ce genre d'analyse.
C'est pas la vérité scientifique,
blablabla.
C'est parti, vous êtes prêt?
Loïc générique...
Il y en a déjà eu un ?
...C'est ça ...
Et bien, c'est incroyable cette histoire.
Très bien.
Alors, une anecdote.
Qui est vraie.
Ça, c'est le premier truc qu'il y a eu où je me ...
C'est intéressant parce que dans sa
posture et tout, bon,
il prend quand même quelque chose
de très stable Emmanuel Macron
et il joint les mains, etc.
Il joue avec eux, etc.
Mais, il commence par dire, pour la
première anecdote,
cette anecdote, attention,
elle est vraie.
Et il fait un pléonasme physique.
Et en général,
un pléonasme physique,
on sait que c'est plutôt
un signe de vérité.
Il dit oui avec sa tête pendant
qu'il dit que c'est vrai.
Sauf que ben, on est quand même
pas sur n'importe quel politicien.
C'est quelqu'un qui a gagné
les élections présidentielles,
qui maîtrise le langage non verbal
et qui a envie, justement,
de les induire en erreur.
À ce moment là, on voit
que le oui, il est forcé.
Il est trop appuyé.
Qu'il regarde vraiment la réaction pour voir
est-ce que ça matche ou pas pour essayer
de mettre de la pression et qu'on a
le visage un petit peu vers le bas?
Donc, c'est un oui, mais en même temps,
on dit en général,
que quand on a le visage vers le bas,
c'est plutôt qu'on a quelque chose
à cacher, qu'on a une honte qu'on
a quelque chose comme ça.
Donc là, moi,
dès ce moment précis, j'avais mis
mon avis sur l'anecdote qui va suivre est
fausse.
Je ne sais pas de quoi ça allait
parler, mais j'ai fait comme ça.
Alors, il y a des fois où je me suis trompé.
Je vous dirais aussi
il y a eu des moments,
des signaux contre-intuitifs ou j'étais
persuadé d'avoir raison et ... j'avais tort.
Mais là, pour moi, c'était faux
et tout le reste n'a presque
pas d'intérêt tellement tout se joue là, en fait.
Donc, vous aimez le foot tous les deux?
Oui, tout à fait.
Kylian Mbappé,
c'est moi qui m'occupe de sa carrière.
Et donc, Kylian Mbappé va quitter le PSG,
dans les prochaines semaines,
pour l'Olympique de Marseille.
Oui, ce serait genre une exclu
incroyable !
Est-ce que l'anecdote est terminée Monsieur le Président?
L'anecdote est terminée.
Et voilà.
Sur cette première anecdote,
la deuxième chose qu'il faut juste retenir,
c'est qu'il n'y
a aucun détail superflu.
Ce n'est que l'essentiel qui est
en général un symbole de mensonge.
Parce que quand on raconte une vraie
anecdote ou un vrai truc,
on dit des choses parasites
et on va le voir d'ailleurs tout de suite
dans la prochaine.
On est au Nigeria.
J'y étais quand j'étais
jeune fonctionnaire
en stage là-bas, pendant six mois.
Vous voyez déjà la différence
avec la première anecdote.
Il cherche ses mots, il respire et il
ne sait pas encore comment formuler.
Parce que, justement,
il y a trop de choses à dire.
En tant
que Président de la République,
j'y suis retourné.
Au Nigeria, la capitale administrative...
Et là, quand il dit... - Tu pourras faire
un petit retour en arrière s'il te plaît Loïc -
... en tant que Président
de la République,
j'y suis retourné.
On voit que là, il a le pléonasme physique
du oui et on voit,
par rapport à tout à l'heure ...
... si tu peux me faire
un petit versus, Loïc ..
Tout à l'heure,
son oui forcé, il était comme ça.
Là, son vrai oui inconscient,
ça a été juste un coup de tête, en fait.
On arrive là bas,
programme officiel, etc.
Et j'avais le souvenir d'un lieu qui est
un peu emblématique de...
... à la fois de la fête, mais de la culture
de l'Afrobeat, qui a été créée là-bas,
qui s'appelle le Shrine.
Qui est une discothèque ?
Qui est le lieu où Kuti,
qui était le très
grand musicien, a vraiment inven...
Là, c'est pareil.
On peut voir que quand il lui
demande des détails sur le lieu,
Emmanuel Macron qui switche pas mal
de regards à droite, à gauche,
là, vire complètement pour revenir.
Et ça, c'est pareil en général
quand on coupe le regard.
C'est vraiment pour se
rappeler un vrai souvenir.
En fait, on se déparasite du regard de l'autre
pour aller chercher un détail
et revenir sur eux.
Et on me dit : "et bien maintenant, vous allez
tourner dans une série avec nous".
Un petit rôle principal .. un petit rôle.
Et donc on me met le scotch, le machin ...
Et je me retrouve au milieu du plateau..
Et c'est là où moi, je mets
mon jeton vérité à 100%.
Il dit : "On me met le scotch, le machin."
Si c'était faux,
s'il n'avait pas vécu ça, il dirait :
bon, ben voilà, on me met un micro
ou je vais sur le plateau.
Ça, c'est le genre de détail inutile,
dont je vous parle souvent,
et qui sont "symbole de vérité".
Quand il dit : "voilà, on me met le scotch,
le machin.." Pour dire le scotch, le machin,
c'est vraiment revisualiser qu'on t'a mis
un truc, qu'on te l'a collé ici, etc. etc..
Ça, c'était le plus
grand symbole de vérité.
Mais en tant que comédien, du coup?
Et du coup, j'ai donné la réplique.
Tu es en train de gagner, en fait.
Tu es en train d'imaginer quelles
photos on aura dans ce cadre.
Et là, quand il répond à la question
en tant que comédien, du coup.
Et qu'il dit : "là, j'ai donné la réplique".
Il se rend compte, et on le voit,
qu'il aimerait encore en parler
comme un symbole de vérité,
mais que lui-même se reprend un peu mentalement
en se disant : "wow wow wow, il ne
faut pas que j'en donne trop non plus.
Si j'en donne trop, ils vont,
ils vont être sûrs que c'est la vérité.
Et le but, c'est quand
même de les bluffer, quoi".
Donc là, il y avait tous les signaux
de vérité sur cette anecdote.
Ce qui montre encore une fois que plus
une anecdote est longue,
plus on peut avoir les éléments qui vont
confirmer que ça va être plutôt la vérité
ou qui vont confirmer que ça va
être potentiellement un mensonge.
On est en short,
habillé, en tenue de footing
... détail inutile ...
En matinée, on prend la voiture, etc.
Je les vois qui sortent... qui commencent à sortir
de Marseille.
Il y a un chemin sinueux qui monte.
Les types sont très sérieux.
On a trouvé un coin pour faire du footing qui est super.
Et d'un seul coup, je vois
au détour d'un virage se dessiner...
Vous pouvez remarquer une chose,
là, je le vois à postériori parce
que j'avais déjà vu la vidéo,
on regarde aussi
la variation des mouvements.
Vous savez, on dit : quelqu'un qui touche beaucoup
le visage, il ment peut-être ... Quelqu'un
qui fait plein de mouvements,
il ment peut-être...
En vrai,
ce n'est ni l'un, ni l'autre. C'est :
quelles sont les variations? En vrai
dans la détection du mensonge,
tu ne cherches que la variation émotionnelle
et après, tu te dis c'est peut-être un
signe du mensonge.
C'est ça qui se passe.
Et Emmanuel Macron, en fait.
Quand il dit la vérité,
quand il raconte une anecdote vraie,
il a tendance à avoir plein de mouvements
parce qu'en fait, il se sent libre.
Il n'a rien à retenir.
Alors que quand il était en mensonge,
comme pour Kylian Mbappé tout à l'heure,
il garde en général les mains
et il se contrôle beaucoup plus.
Là, il y a énormément
de mouvements dans cette anecdote.
Un lieu qui s'ouvre avec
plein de bâtiments autour
et je vois la Commanderie.
C'est fou ... pour les gestes.
Parce que ça permet ça
aussi, cette vidéo, de se dire ok,
c'est quoi les signaux d'Emmanuel
Macron ?
La Situation Room, c'est comme ça que ça s'appelle
côté américain, veut vous joindre.
Je dis ok, très bien.
Je me rends disponible très vite.
Je réorganise les choses.
Je vais dans mon bureau parce que c'est
un téléphone qui est sécurisé.
On passe l'appel et le Président Trump,
c'est toujours très rapide
les discussions avec lui.
Il appelait facilement,
mais c'était très, très rapide.
Là, il dit : "Salut Emmanuel,
comment vas-tu?  etc.
Alors celle-ci, elle est passionnante parce que moi,
je me suis fait avoir.
Je pensais qu'elle était
vraie et elle était fausse.
Et du coup, là,
je le regarde et je l'analyse
en mode aussi :
Pourquoi moi je me suis trompé,
quand j'ai regardé?
Parce qu'on retrouve tous les gestes
de main qu'il a d'habitude
quand il dit la vérité.
Parce qu'il
y a des petits détails inutiles.
Et en fait, je suis en train de voir
des variations que je n'avais pas eu
au premier coup d'oeil
par rapport à d'habitude.
Il y a... Je vais la remettre à zéro....
Il y a le moment où il remet sa montre.
C'est pas des gestes qu'il a
d'habitude et ça peut être des gestes
pour se rassurer.
Il y a beaucoup plus de mouvements
d'épaules saccadés qu'il
n'a pas d'habitude avant.
Et il y a aussi
une déglutition gorge sèche.
Et on sait que les émotions fortes
et le stress, ça assèche la bouche.
Donc, c'est un signe du mensonge.
Et vraiment, pour être très honnête,
je me suis complètement fait avoir
quand j'ai regardé la vidéo hier.
Celle-ci, j'ai mis un jeton
vraiment en mode sur-vérité.
Pas du tout !
Ce qui arrive régulièrement quand on...
Pourtant, il retourne souvent au contrôle
des mains par rapport à d'habitude.
Mais, il les bouge !
Habituellement, sur les mensonges,
il ne les bougeait pas.
... "côté américain, veut vous joindre ...
je dis ok, très bien.
..La montre...
Très vite, je réorganise les choses.
Je vais dans mon bureau parce que c'est
un téléphone qui est sécurisé.
On passe l'appel ... Le mouvement d'épaule ...
... les discussions avec lui ... il appelait facilement...
mais c'était très très rapide.
Là, il dit ... déglutissement... etc.
En anglais dans le texte.
Hi Emmanuel. How are you?
Fine, and you?
I'm Donald Trump
Il y avait des indices,
mais ils étaient beaucoup plus
subtils sur lui.
Est-ce que tu vas bien?
Et il me dit : "je t'appelais pour te
souhaiter un très bon anniversaire".
Ah ... et ça aussi, j'aurais dû le voir.
Ce qu'on peut voir,
c'est que quand il parle de son assistante,
il baisse les yeux et là,
il a besoin aussi de construire son truc
en même temps, et quand il disait
la vérité, il allait chercher en haut.
Comme tout le monde, en fait.
En tout cas, on tourne le regard....
Il fait ... attends, on était
le jeudi, c'est ça.
Là, chaque fois qu'il cherche, il regarde en bas,
souvenez-vous ce que je
vous ai dit au début de la vidéo.
En général, quand on regarde vers le bas,
c'est qu'on est un peu quelque chose
à cacher, un peu un sentiment de honte.
Et là, on l'a exactement ...
... est-ce que tu vas bien?
Et il me dit : "je t'appelais pour te
souhaiter un très bon anniversaire, etc."
Il n'avait rien à me dire, il a raccroché.
Situation Room pour bon anniversaire ?!
Et même là, il malaxe ses mains.
Il n'a pas la même aisance que d'habitude.
N'empêche qu'il est très très bon bluffeur,
parce que, a
regarder vite fait comme moi hier,
il y avait plutôt quand même
les signaux de vérité, quoi.
Voilà pour cette vidéo que vous m'avez
tant demandée sur Twitter,
sur Insta, sur Facebook.
Ça a même réactivé mon compte Copains
d'Avant (alors que je n'étais pas inscrit).
Mais, j'espère que ça vous a plu.
Encore une fois,
c'était juste pour repasser quelques fois
sur les temps intéressants du Président.
En fait, est-ce que c'est un bon
bluffeur ou pas un bon bluffeur?
Du coup, Loïc, tu dis
que c'est un bon bluffeur?
Il est très très bon bluffeur, selon moi.
Et pour que je me plante sur une lecture
d'anecdote comme ça,
je ne dis pas que je suis meilleur du monde,
mais je dis que, en vidéo,
c'est quand même plus simple,
on peut repasser dessus.
En plus là, je l'avais déjà vue en amont.
Je suis passé à côté de certains signaux
parce qu'ils étaient quand même
très légers, voire inexistants.
Donc, excellent bluffeur.
Moi, il me reste une question : "est-ce que il n'est pas
tellement bon bluffeur,
qu'il a parfois fait semblant de mal bluffer
pour qu'on pense qu'il est bon bluffeur
ou pas?
Je sais pas.
Et ça, on ne le saura
jamais les gars.
Jamais.
Mais bon bluffeur....
Et en soi, au moins
moi je suis content que cette vidéo ait
existé, au moins pour pouvoir faire ce
travail là qui est un peu inédit, en fait,
d'avoir un homme politique haut placé qui,
face à un concours d'anecdotes,
mensonges, vérités.
C'est une matière incroyable,
quand on est mentaliste et qu'on veut
chercher à étudier ça.
Si ça vous a plu, n'oubliez
pas de liker cette vidéo.
N'hésitez pas à la partager.
Moi, je m'appelle toujours Fabien Olicard.
Je suis toujours content de vous voir.
Vous pouvez vous abonner,
c'est gratuit en cliquant ici
et en activant la cloche, évidemment,
pour voir les nouvelles vidéos.
Et sinon, j'ai un livre qui est sorti,
il y a quelques temps,
qui s'appelle :
L'antiguide de la manipulation.
ça tombe bien !
Peut-être ça peut vous intéresser.
Je vous mets le lien dans la description
et le visuel c'est celui-ci.
Prenez soin de vous.
Je vous mets
deux autres analyses ici.
A très bientôt.
Tchao !